letzte sendung vor dem fest meine damen
und herren und schon wieder fragen wir
uns banken was für ein weihnachten wird
er's welche verwandte darf man noch
einladen im moment gehen die instanzen
runter während im hintergrund die
omikron welle anlauf nimmt aber dagegen
wird ja angebot hat bis dem nadel glüht
hey was soll man da noch die
festtagslaune versauen aber in der tat
aus wir haben zu wenig impfstoff und das
hat viele überrascht in der inventur
mich auch
gott sie haben jetzt inventur gemacht
wirklich ganz wichtig ich bin mich vom
fach aber hätte man nicht schon längst
prophylaktisch mal durchzählen können
was noch so im regal liegt bei penny und
edeka schaffen sie das auch jeden tag
wer bitte wer bitte ist dafür laut
lauterbach schon wieder verantwortlich
ach so ja nachkommt nachtreten macht
auch keinen spaß obwohl das neuerdings
sogar in der bundespressekonferenz
passiert hier neulich sehr schön zu
beobachten bei spahns verabschiedung und
achten sie sehen unter anderem mal auf
das gesicht vom wähler sei dank gilt
natürlich auch an herrn wieder bei ihm
hoffen wir auf ein baldiges wiedersehen
bei ihnen zumindest in dieser funktion
vermutlich nicht
wenn lothar wieler lachen muss war der
witz wirklich gut so kann man sich
merken übrigens andere behaupten
lauterbach habe bei der inventur falsch
gezählt aber uns bürger interessiert ihn
nur noch eins wie lässt sich der nächste
lockdown noch verhindern
vielleicht mit hilfe des so genannten
expertenrats der seit dieser woche karl
lauterbach berät 19 personen aus allen
möglichen fachrichtungen helfen da der
politik sehr gut und jetzt kommt mit
dabei christian drosten und hendrik
strikt im selben raum das ist so als ob
du die bandidos und die hells angels ein
letzt natürlich die wurden uns doch
medial immer als große rivalen verkauft
hier sollte ich mir den ersten
expertenrat vorgestellt
ist natürlich totaler quatsch ich habe
jetzt gelesen die beiden verstehen sich
sogar ganz gut
langweilig so und dann diskutieren wir
seit dieser woche natürlich übers kinder
impfen
super lied von rolf zuckowski und seinen
freunden gut das muss man zugeben das
ist jetzt wirklich eine sehr persönliche
entscheidung der eltern von fünf bis
zwölfjährigen die ja stand heute selber
kein großes krankheitsrisiko tragen
andererseits muss man wohl abwarten wie
bedrohlich sich omikron für genau diese
altersgruppe entwickelt allein das wort
kinder impfen ist für einige erwachsene
sehr emotional ja
verständlicherweise die kleinen selber
sind da oft viel pragmatischer in vielen
familien werden gerade die rollen quasi
getauscht mama mein impftermin ich will
aber nicht dass du nicht ins lässt man
gott bei jeder in das gleiche theater
ist ja gut
du hast mir danach auf 5 globuli den
versprochen ja
gut manche kinderärzte raten auch lieber
noch auf den omikron impfstoff zu warten
ich wäre schon happy wenn wir irgendwann
aus unseren corona fehlern lernen würden
alle experten haben gesagt wenn die
südhalbkugel des planeten zu wenig
impfstoff kriegt rächt sich dass mit
einer mutation zack passiert und warum
werden immer noch versprechungen gemacht
die man sowieso nicht halten kann diese
woche ist es wieder während drei mal
geimpft es braucht keine tests mehr
wenn deutschland ein schüler wäre was
für eine note bekämen wir wohl in corona
so deutschland zwei jahre pandemie
management wie würdest du dich dann
selber einschätzen also für meine erste
panini fand ich jetzt gar nicht so
schlecht ich habe mich gut beteiligt war
pünktlich bei klar bin ich nicht immer
ganz mitgekommen mit dem stoff nicht
hatte kurz probleme beim masken kauf mit
tests mit dem stoff mit zu wenig
geimpften mit wellenbrecher lockdown mit
brücken lockdown mit normalen lockdown
zweig kontrollen 3g kontrollen mit
kontrollen insgesamt
mit nicht ausgezahlten hilfsgelder h ist
gut deutschland mein gott das war eine
rhetorische frage
das ist eine frage wo man die antwort
schon kennen ich sag jetzt mal ganz
offen deutschland eine versetzung ist
akut gefährdet
ja jetzt guckt mich so traurig weil es
muss auch nicht jedes land aufs
gymnasium
moment mal soll das heißt ich bin doof
oder was also doof ist jetzt ein hartes
wort sang mama du bist
besonders
besonders doof
und das erkennt man zum beispiel daran
wofür du dein vieles geld ausgibt und
wofür nicht trotz förderprogrammen haben
laut aktuellem schul barometer einer
umfrage unter lehrkräften bundesweit 72
prozent der schulen keine luftfilter
geräte im einsatz es gibt aber große
regionale unterschiede in bayern haben
40 prozent der schulen luftfilter in
ganz ostdeutschland nur acht prozent
ja aber das kann ich erklären da gab es
nämlich gerade eine anfrage an die
bundesregierung und da hat mein
wirtschaftsministerium geantwortet das
lüften viel besser ist als ich zitiere
kostenintensive geräte die nach der
pandemie unter umständen nicht mehr
benötigt werden so diese luftfilter sind
nämlich voll teuer
genau deswegen stehen wir auch in
behörden und parlamenten weil da die
leute arbeiten die dir wichtig sind
deutschland im gegensatz zu deinen
kindern
ich habe gar nichts gegen kinder das
sind ja im weitesten sinne auch fast
menschen deswegen hat der bund ja auch
fördermittel für luftfilter
bereitgestellt
fördermittel von denen bisher genau null
euro abgerufen wurden weil nämlich
ausschließlich filter in klassenräumen
gefördert werden in denen zitat die
fenster nur kipp ba sind und oder die
über lüftungsklappen mit minimalem
querschnitt verfügen was immer der
scheiß bedeuten soll dabei sagen
sperrten der deutschen
forschungsgemeinschaft
lüften allein reicht nicht zusätzlich
aerosolen rausfiltern hilft enorm und
wenn man demnächst wegen omikron doch
wieder schulen dicht machen dann tust du
überrascht deutschland oder machst du
wieder dein blödes gesicht weil du blöd
bist und bleibst
zumal sich an der technischen
ausstattung für den distanz unterricht
weiterhin kaum was getan habt schon
allein kinder in quarantäne digital in
die klasse zu holen ist schwierig da
fehlt es dann ja doch noch in manchen
klassenräume an materielle ausstattung
wir haben eine weit projektor hier in
der kasse
ich verstehe jetzt overhead mich wo das
problem ist com deutschland das hat doch
alles keinen sinn so ich stufe ich jetzt
mal offiziell ein als land mit
förderbedarf
so und jetzt raus ich muss mich um den
nächsten problem schüler kümmern das
bundesland sachsen hallo sachsen
was glaubst du [ __ ]
nichts beate schneider
[Applaus]
wirte schneider eigentlich müssten wir
als deutschland tatsächlich sitzen
bleiben es ist so am letzten wochenende
sind wieder demos gegen korona maßnahmen
eskaliert allein im thüringischen greiz
wurden 14 polizisten verletzt klar auch
bei den ungeimpften sollte man immer
differenzieren was ihre motive angeht
aber bei gewalttätigen demos direkt
neben nazis gegen die spaltung der
gesellschaft protestieren findet den
fehler wir sind nicht willkommen
sie sahen einen ausschnitt aus dem
musical könig der löwen wohlgemerkt das
grundrecht friedlich zu demonstrieren
muss man energisch verteidigen aber wir
haben uns schon gefragt wem oder was
verleiht man jetzt im zusammenhang mit
diesen gewalttätigen protesten den
goldenen vollpfosten und dann ist es uns
einen gefallen meine damen und herren
telegramm natürlich wem denn sonst
völlig richtig oliver telegramm die
digitale heimat des wahnsinns der
wichtigste bullshit multiplikator
unserer tage ist es ein messenger dienst
oder doch nur social media plattform
egal hauptsache selbst
holocaust-leugnung bleibt unzensiert
stehen auf kanälen mit bis zu
200.000 abonnenten die das nennen wir es
mal offene wort lieben ja wo kann man
denn heutzutage sonst noch mordfantasien
gegen politiker und journalisten aus
leben nur bei telegramm viele der leute
die damals gemacht sind gehören
eigentlich aufgegeben
ansonsten wissen will was sagen wie
schön
tatsächlich läuft gegen telegramm ein
deutsches bußgeldverfahren leider hat es
das bundesamt für justiz seit april mich
mal geschafft ein anhörungsschreiben
zuzustellen was also tun gegen telegramm
mit sitz in dubai gut eine möglichkeit
wäre dass der staat die ganzen deppen
die unter klarnamen zb impfärzte
bedrohen einfach mal juristisch verfolgt
andererseits du kannst so viel lernen
auf telegramm hier zb wussten sie dass
wenn ich mir beim sex spielen von meinem
querdenker kumpel in den arm kneifen
lassen und mich wochenlang nicht waschen
dann bleibt ein schlüssel an meinem
körper schweiß hängen also ohne solche
experimente wüssten wer das gar nicht
das nennt man wissenschaft
zelebrant ist angeblich eine
non-profit-organisation die also nur aus
spaß unsere demokratie zersetzt aber wer
braucht profite wenn er den goldenen
vollpfosten hat in der exklusiven im
nazi edition wusstest du schon
lauterbacher gar nicht studiert coruna
gibt es nur um die diktatur zu
installieren die teststäbchen sind
radioaktiv kein wunder dass das noch
nicht in der tagesschau lief vom bus
erstarrte kleine oman aids die särge aus
italien die waren alle fake merkel ist
der sohn von hitlers frau auf dem foto
hier sieht man das doch ganz genau du
sagst dass ich das alles nicht beweisen
kann aber glaubt mir da stand doch
telegramm das alles kann nicht ganz
einfach beweisen man nicht wer es
standhaft telegramm deutschland hat noch
immer keinen friedensvertrag wir sind
eine firma und überhaupt kein staat guck
mal auf seinen personalausweis dann
sollst du endlich auch warum der so heiß
die große finanz entscheidet doch schon
lange über und wer das nicht weiß denkt
bei bilderberg an kunst ich sage nur
zwei wörter great result was das spitze
frag mich nicht du sagst was alles nicht
beweisen kann aber glaubt mir das
telegramm keine gesetze und keine zensur
der letzte freie orten der korona
diktatur hast du gewusst was glaubst du
nie telegramm gehört jetzt in rk du
fragt wie ich das einfach so behaupten
kann ich sag's hier ich bin jetzt auch
abziele
[Musik]
so kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
kanal hier danke euer gernot hassknecht
so ich gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen zschau